[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so jan he's coming by today because i
want to do this project with him but
because it's also jan he's going to try
to murder us all with nerf guns the
thing is jan has never been able to get
a full team wipe and i think it's
because he has a slight handicap
basically jan's missing his pinky finger
do you know how he actually lost his
finger uh well i heard that he lost it
in a blender
like it was a mad weird blender incident
i heard it was in a threshing accident
in the old country every story he tells
us he says is the right story but i want
to know the real story so what if i do
him such a nice favor that he has no
choice but
to give me the real story and that is
why i asked him to come by the studio
today
did you hear that yeah
he's going to give me a whole
hand
so this all started when i found a 3d
printed prosthetic finger on thingiverse
and it turns out the guy who made that
named nick has a whole website dedicated
to this prosthetic he wrote an entire
program that takes measurement inputs
from your finger stump and it'll
actually generate an entirely new 3d
model specifically designed for your
finger socket so you've already read up
about this guy a little bit because you
share an injury and you're like i can
relate to this guy i mean we have very
very similar stories there she i was
kidnapped by the old man that lives out
in the sawmill and i was tied
to a a log and being put through a
logging machine and you know i was
trying to push the rope toward the saw
and my finger got caught in there
luckily it got the rope uh i i got free
and then you know
we we duked it out for a while and yeah
yeah what happened to the old man oh man
we're actually real good friends
he feels
pretty bad about the finger so i know
jan likes butterfly knives and like
spinning blade tricks and i heard he was
using like a cigar cutter it's kind of
like a fidget spinner in a bar once and
it pinches him right up against his body
as he's spinning it and
i guess the rest is history all right so
here's what happened jan as a teenager
used to work in a morgue he helped his
dad out one night they were staying late
he was down with the bodies he heard a
sound
what did you say something or did you
hear something
i heard the scrape
of what i could only call a creature too
large for the room and as i was running
just just pulling myself through the
room i remember seeing red somewhere
around the stairs i realized i was
missing a finger was that before or
after you got kidnapped
what is before what is after i have
reasons to suspect that maybe that story
was a little embellished
you solely my name sir well i mean i
don't have to make this thing for you
oh
i would like to have a new finger tell
you what jim if i succeed in making you
a new prosthetic finger
you have to tell me the real story that
is an interesting dilemma isn't it
yes i have to take the lavaliers i have
to make sure there are no recording
equipment going and then you may have
that story in exchange
for a functioning hand
[Music]
deal
all right jan i think we are ready to
start taking measurements
i have been waiting for this since i
lost my finger in that deep underground
military base in the desert it's really
important we get these measurements
right so that this thing will actually
fit i don't want this to be a gimmick i
don't want him to throw this away the
moment this video's over i want him to
actually find usefulness out of this
thing so for that's work it has to fit
him well and it has to work well i want
to wear this i want this to be a new
part of my look putting on a prosthetic
should be as comfortable as possible so
you are actually going to use it the
second it's more of a hindrance than it
is a help what's the point so we got the
most important measurements taken the
reason why the socket is the most
important part is because it is the
point of contact between the prosthetic
and your hand and so that is where all
the force is going to be applied that's
where all the abrasive like rubbing is
going to be applied you want to make
sure that is the most comfortable fit as
possible because after we're done with
v1 i'd like a knife finger i'd like a
you know what i do actually legitimately
think we can do that
okay so i guess now i just gotta go sit
down on my computer and see if i can
actually input these things this is
where a bunch of problem solving occurs
where i try to just get something that
works
this is supposed to be easy it's
supposed to be the simplest
thing ever
but no
jan's involved so it's not simple i mean
that's pretty much par for the course of
my entire life so yeah
um let's just see how it looks
so jan
this is not a good quality print what
happened
anyway um
this in theory should fit
no there's too much room that's way too
much room yeah what about length and
stuff
it needs to be a wee bit longer so i
think it's just a matter of shrinking
that diameter dang i was really hoping
this was going to fit a lot better i
just gotta print a bunch of variations i
think so i think i might just make small
little variations jen's gonna come by
tomorrow afternoon and hopefully by then
i'll just have like a selection of
variations i'm gonna try each one out on
jan to see which one fits the best
oh god i am just oh hold up
[Music]
okay so i've done some printing jan i
can't wait to see oh shut up you got
like a full finger apparatus going i
printed three different versions of the
socket sure and this is in the the
flexible uh oh yeah shut up that's tpu
so i'll have you try these on one at a
time to see which one fits the best
let's start with this one
i mean that does not feel terrible i'll
tell you that right now if it was a
little longer it'd be
i think a little more secure how does
like the squeeze feel feels good okay so
these two are going to be a little bit
different
let's give it a shot it feels looser but
the fact that it's holding and i don't i
don't feel pressure on it i think that's
actually a good sign because maybe this
i would forget about after a while you
know this has a bit of a bigger taper so
yeah this one legit feels like i would
eventually forget about it like it would
just uh after a period of time because
this one it felt more snug exactly too
tight like tight to a point of
discomfort i would like it to feel like
it's not going to come off but i could
also forget about it
this is what it's going to look like
on you
that would be
radical
just
get a little knife on the end of that
yeah that would be amazing that's cool
it does look good on you i need to mark
that one that's the one you want i still
got to figure out exactly how the
linkage system works and additionally i
need to actually get a proper print of
that socket jan you are this much closer
to being able to do this
to the power of 10.
so check this out we have this actual
working prosthetic finger it's actually
kind of funny this was actually a little
bit more challenging to put together
than i anticipated i don't know if this
is technically the way it goes together
but you know what it does work there's
like basically the series of strings
there's three separate strings woven
inside here two are elastic one is this
high strength fishing line and they each
serve different purposes the two elastic
strings serve one purpose which is to
actually keep the thing extended
straight and then the braided fishing
line here serves a second purpose of
actually pulling it closed this will go
on jan's stump of a finger like so so
then the idea is that this attaches to
there
so then every time the finger then bends
forward it causes the fingers to bend
biomechanics took billions of years to
get to this point and i made it in a day
so the big thing is i'm just going to
have to grind down these center pins for
the hinges i need to file the actual
gray plastic parts here so that they're
smoother with less friction and make
sure that i can print the tpu bit
without having an entire layer shift two
millimeters into the print my hope is
that jan actually is able to use this
next time he comes in it's because i
need to deliver the final thing to him
cause if i don't do that i'll never hear
the real story from jan stay with me
here for a second okay jan loves to
listen to music he rides around on his
onewheel and every month he has a new
discography of a new artist that he goes
through and listens to until he's done
with that artist courtesy of today's
sponsor ray khan i wanted to propose a
few design improvements as a nice
personal touch now ren's pretty
particular when it comes to his
engineering hopefully he'll be open to
including some of these ideas
oh
what
i think it would be really cool if not
only did we give him a new finger but
also we included an audio feature to
that finger imagine sticking your finger
in your ear and hearing crisp clean
audio providing the same sound quality
as any other premium earbud on the
market but coming at a much more
affordable much more reasonable price
they have more bass and it's just pretty
much a nice flawless clean design who
wants to listening you just be like
hello he's getting it
now i noticed that you've printed this
finger in green raycons come in all of
your different favorite colors so check
out this carrying case right not only
does this give you a convenient place to
keep your earbuds when you're traveling
about town but also it provides
recharging and each recharge gives you
up to six hours of play time that means
jan can ride around on his wheel for up
to six hours without having to stick him
back in the charging case i love
charging cases i think they're a
brilliant idea the other thing that they
do is they have seamless bluetooth
pairing so if you can get bluetooth in
this it'll seamlessly bluetooth pair
with the raycon buds without your finger
open up the finger yeah then you got
earbuds
and uh we give them 15 off by going to
byraycon.com
corridor crew is that by raycon.com
corridor crew for 15 off 15 off
wow
what up i'm kind of curious how did you
lose your finger
so remember that um it was this video
for far cry part of the script required
sam to lose his pinky on set right it
was a knife going into a pinky that was
supposed to be the gag but the effect
was actually so difficult they started
saying well it'd be way easier if
someone just actually did it i'm no wuss
so when someone said just cut off your
finger
[Music]
that's why that looks so real
exactly exactly
got it working i've got it working check
this out it works and now i just got to
fit it to jan so there's a little bit of
left to do but it requires a jan stubby
mcnugget here to actually work
wait that's jen is that jan is he here
dude
oh you got me dang dude
and you missed oh where's sam and nathan
wait are you actually gonna get a team
sweep i might
yes
you got him come here
you did it
dude
enough of the team wipe i gotta give you
the finger i i can't wait to receive the
power of ten
oh man
oh man that's so cool
that's good
yeah
no that feels comfy we're gonna make jan
a little bracelet real quick this
bracelet is gonna go on his wrist and
that's what we're actually gonna tie the
ligament to that will actually cause the
whole finger to curl closed
yeah yeah it's working we're in there oh
my god it's working
it's working you made a pivotal mistake
ren
you should have never given me the power
of time
dude that's so crazy to see can you give
me one of these
yeah
this camera's just open if you can pick
this up with just your thumb and pinky
i'd be incredibly impressed
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's like all these muscles in my
hand that i don't think i've ever
activated it's a weird feeling a weird
feeling all those muscles would have
atrophied from never being used yeah all
right before we go show everyone i have
one more surprise gift for you okay
shut up
it's a knife finger
i modeled and printed this this morning
slick the pain flick the pain
i think i may have unleashed too much
power into this world
you really do have nice hair nico do you
do anything to that hair pinky swear
this is the first
left-handed pinky square
it's a corrupted pinky sweater
that's really cool
so these are my my greaves um i wear
them when i ride one wheels and that
combined with the finger works
so well let's see it yeah
[Applause]
oh yeah
wow
do you feel that pinky i do it doesn't
even feel any different because it's
part of you
wow you've never felt the grasp of your
pinky before well at least on this hand
sanitize your hands now sanitize your
hands all right jan
it is time i fulfilled my side of the
bargain i deserve the pure story i
absolutely will give you that story
i'm reiterating no mike's in the room no
no tomfoolery
you get the story and you alone and uh
yeah you have given me the power of ten
i have to give you the power of pure
truth pure knowledge
[Music]
dude nick you won't believe the dream i
just had
i guess i'll never actually learn what
the real story is behind jan's finger
if you think you know what it is leave a
comment down below i'd like to read what
you think
in the meantime thanks for watching
subscribe for more videos like this
but for now
nighty night